alors les roulettes qui font aussi la
joie des adeptes de la luge à villard de
lans dans le vercors un ancien
compétiteur des jeux olympiques
d'albertville s'est lancé dans
l'aventuré frissons garantis pour les
touristes qui s'y essaye virginie fiche
et philippe visé par quatre grands
prison
240 mètres de glisse à 70 km heure de
pointe de la luge sans glace nilan
affûté mais avec des bolides de
compétition tout de même montés sur
roulettes c'est tout bon
alors proportionnellement ça va un petit
peu moins vite et là messieurs c'est
stella ne verrait pas la différence
s'inquiète une ses fans verront pas la
différence par contre la grosse
différence qu'il ya pour quelqu'un qui
sait en faire c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
moins de jeu latéral c'est à dire de
dérapages possibles dans le parcours
l'idée a germé dans la tête de l'ancien
lui jeux olympiques il y a trois ans
avec son père ils ont réalisé cette
piste en fibre de verre et résine
polyester 1500 heures de travail twitter
le circuit donne quelques palpitations
ou vacanciers casse-cou ans pour piloter
en appui sur la jambe gauche quand vous
tournez sur la droite ouais et avec
l'épaule en appui comme ça il en tient
actuellement on voit le core model temps
de faire tout ça 2800 tour par descente
les roulettes encaisse le coeur des
touristes aussi
ya l'estomac qui fait des noeuds et puis
à part quelques vagues on verra je vous
dirais comme si on était sûr n'a nagé
contre qu'on glisse avec eux des skis
sont allongés et qu'on est sur un canapé
à la fin du moins l'équipe de france de
luge elle-même viendra s'entraîner ici
en attendant les champions voici la
longue glissade grandeur nature
à prouver dessous
décidément tout le monde est essoufflé